hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm here with my scrim who is Bob and
Lord minion seven seven seven who is
Wade and we are here with season two of
drunk minecraft now we are actually
gonna have serious objectives to
introduce yourselves oh I forgot about
that
I'm late
let's try too hard wait like do a look
at this uh oh let's keep it moving
Marta I am my skirt my name is Bob I
haven't seen you guys since mark had
like a hundred thousand subscribers less
than this so yeah there's a hundred
thousand people who don't know who the
[ __ ] this guy is yeah okay these two are
my good friends and big parts of drunk
minecraft the only parts really yeah so
we are back and this this um this year I
don't know this season a new year yeah
we're gonna have um actual objectives
and what our objective today is we are
going to be building towers of iron iron
blocks iron blocks distinction and in 25
minutes we're gonna try to see who can
build the tallest tower of iron and
obtained through whatever means
necessary and on this little platform
whether it be digging stealing or
finding the magic drops that are gonna
appear throughout the world by our
mysterious apparition estai would look
at this tremendous view of us from way
on high is he over there without sound
look at the camera so round camera okay
what rallies are they [ __ ] in the sky he
it's like a bit of an omni max okay
anyway it's ourselves now we're to do
that no we did that we did that Wade you
had your chance you screwed it up I'm
Lord Indian seven song played you go now
now now the game shall begin in three
two one go
are those bleachers already oh my go get
away from me get your goodies good darn
there's goodies yes we got to get iron
Utah remember I think wait we're
building a house right wait this is just
gon be just fool around don't do
anything oh okay so we are obtaining
iron through whatever means necessary
whether that be digging or finding the
magical chests that are going to appear
the chesticles hey guys I found the
surprise twist ending what did you ever
see sixth sense
uh yes our Bruce witless we are Bruce
Willis doesn't make any sense it will if
you come to where I'm at mark what no
I'm doing it's a trick I'm tagging iron
cuz I'm funny I show mark what I speak
of what the second view way up high I I
don't know if you have to announce it
like that every time that's gonna happen
Oh God it's a new feature oh it's it's
almost as if whoa wait why don't you
dare I'm sorry you pack I have to give
you this dirt block No oh you guys are
so dumb wai-wai-wait what the ah my
grave I told you what you wouldn't come
glad to send you to the beyond uh uh uh
uh
whoa you guys not hearing me laughs
maniacally so Baba are you that's pretty
normal
just like a normal day hanging out with
Mark so at the end of this someone's
gonna end up standing on top of one iron
block and they'll be the winner cuz
we're [ __ ] stupid
no we're gonna get this just fine I am
now oh we're dealt the iron go oh no I
got you it's in my inventory I found it
I found it I found it and now I have the
ultimate weapon you guys don't know what
I found in one of the magical chests you
- more graves you sick bastard ha ha ha
it was um uh nothing there was nothing
in the graves at all except for the
chest and like Bob's oh no of course
that was your chair your grave yes my
grave actually had something I asked I
believe us of your bias I in the sky
what do you see oh okay I can't place
torches and there's I heard hahaha I'm
in the darkness oh I fell in a hole it's
very dark there are things around me
it's bad I'm gonna lose all the iron by
the by all rights to you why that I came
up with this literally the worst plan
anyone's ever had mine might be worse
cuz I am in pitch blackness Oh bye bye
high in the sky I can't see I can't see
it a hot place torches I can't place I
don't have any oh I have torches I can
place torches okay nevermind I I need
not have panicked so much hi oh wow how
did you sneak up on me cuz I fell in a
hole behind you haha boom that's a ball
that is a gun damn it I'm gonna dies
I've got like no faith oh I got a potion
a night vision you guys are screwed
I've got torches like it now please no
Bob I'm defenseless I have it wired
I have no iron Oh get out of here I
think I love it the iron behind oh you
didn't oh that was like 25 blocks of
iron ore or iron or screw this I'm out
of here I'm going away to look for iron
elsewhere cuz I have no
axé anymore I love the progress we've
made on our iron towers so far and we're
already approaching five minutes in Oh
good guy you guys are great
yeah we're great yeah I just think
you've ever said does I still feel like
it's a lie
yeah it might be I have no idea okay so
I well I shouldn't say what I'm doing
out loud no I'm saying I like that yeah
we need to know I'm in commentary mode
with my other series and I I'm going to
sit here and drink more cuz oh oh yeah
that it's really hard to actually drink
while I'm trying to play a competition
Oh how's it oh oh oh that looks
tantalizingly delicious I don't know by
the by our our this this episode of this
episode of drunk minecraft is brought to
you by our Alfred's automotive airport
damn anyone asks me about an awesome
aeronautical adventure
I always approve of Alfred's amazing
aptitude in automotive expertise now
brought to you with wings
hahaha I found it funny wait even though
no one else did I thought it was pretty
everyone always is islet and Bob's drug
haha bob is concentrating on winning the
competition boy no Bobby are mine I am
NOT where you are yes you don't know
[ __ ] hahahahahaha Kevin come on Jimmy
yes you'll not stop me how do I get down
no you know I have a feeling worried
about go back to the graves again oh
[ __ ] oh now I am the winner for I oh
[ __ ]
need a crafting table oh no I'm not
through in her yet
Abbot this is not fair this whole game
is rigged I swear hmm oh I in the sky
could I have a tree here there trees all
around not underground
oh but put a whole forest underground I
in the sky zombie aah
how what was that nothing oh okay clear
now I don't think it was nothing clearly
it was nothing
I think it was something and I know that
Oh God
ah I got almost one whole floor of my
tower built died I'm the greatest god
man that takes a lot of iron oh [ __ ]
that's a zombie with iron on oh I
thought it was you standing around like
a dumbass oh I'll never do that I am
wait me or Wade I don't know one of you
is not me oh he was wearing full iron
armor and a sword and I got nothing ha
ha ha that's the way it works in this
game uh-huh
so wait Oh while we're while we're
trying to murder each other what you
drinkin there Bob I'm not Bob without
drinking English I wasn't talking to you
I'm freakin Maker's Mark bourbon and dye
coke that sounds awesome
I was gonna do whiskey and Sunkist
but I instead changed for grape vodka
and grape soda I've already had a couple
of these we could we could tell hey was
that with me
that means that you sound lovely you
shut your face wait by that means you
sound ugly thank you that's more like it
hey Marcus you say that you would finish
some of your tower yeah no no more tower
hahaha you stay away from my tower if
you break an iron block does it go back
so I'm back to ingot or does it stay a
block I'm not jealous because I know but
no Oh No
okay all right hang on I got a hi zombie
bastard where these zombies hey if he
nice he's our eye-in-the-sky
no I mean there's a gap ha ha ha
I fell oh look look ha ha ha oh did he
just get night yeah it's nighttime now
ok good
all right I found flowers and a bucket
of water
these will surely aid me in my quest
know that we're approaching the
10-minute mark let's see the progress on
the towers from the eye in the sky
Hey wow that's amazing we can look at
that look at that everybody
wow we looking at wow I don't know there
are no towers dammit
alright new rules
it it doesn't have to be two by two it
can be one by one that's what the cars
right oh but I am winning then oh oh you
don't have any towers placed yeah well I
can do that pretty quick I've got a
whole lot of nothing what was what are
you guys seeing this
no no bird's-eye view of whatever the
hell is happening over here
oh no let's not let's stay away from
that I am going to see Oh No you okay
wait no wait what that was a movie this
game is not going burn oh [ __ ] I forgot
the tools break No alright I guess I'll
start over from wool I was still in the
game but I'm pretty far out I gotta
start from wood I got stone so I got a
maples
I don't know what I got did you see my
video today my silly video I did that
was kind of silly that was kinda silly
huh
no from the volcano that's mine get away
get away get away get away
it's the only thing I got I got nothing
else oh my god oh good vanya bastard ah
I hope you burn are you burning no not
anymore I thought water damn it
alright I'll be there just don't do
anything I wouldn't do
hang on are there any more magical
chests in the sky or anything
yes no no is nothing I do not know of
what you speak it's okay you guys will
never find my secret mine uh-huh no what
laughs mark no it's mine you back off
got it guy guy I got I got I got a my my
my my my art is gone
no you burned the iron look you bastard
why why cuz fish sticks
that's not a reason I know doesn't know
you're a fish
okay uh-huh I just wait I just saw that
episode like today no yesterday episode
is whatever you and I went to the casino
mark yeah that was it or was it yes it
was that it okay
by the way uh Wade what's up in thanks
for the iron
haha no it's mine doing doing my sword
skill is fifty I'll lose you in the
forest how did your sword skill go so
high oh okay oh okay young just like old
times buddy up but only your drinks to
me you're already get me I don't even
have that much iron in the sky I got
every oh God
ah you want me on accident oh yeah yeah
yeah let's try to hit mark too bad to
give a bow or something how are you
hitting me
uh you were lagging really [ __ ] oh the
skeleton has a bow that my health is
really low it makes it seem worse when
you get killed by a shabby iron sword ah
spider dr. Knight I don't have anything
I don't have anything she is watching my
pain I don't have a weapon I don't have
anything I have nothing so how's this
project tower going ah if it threw us
off - huh it means I see wait a minute
there's a vision in the sky I see
something something oh oh oh it
disappeared
oh haha I don't know what it was
oh [ __ ] swords are sure I just pure
appear to be lost
are you guys just pvping is that what
you're doing ah ah go away
why are you again hello I'm making out
of the fun I in the sky capture all of
the action that's going on over there I
was gonna work under starving - they're
good
die you bastard oh we're good come from
oh oh oh oh oh yeah oh no hang on wait
which flower do you give golems roses
Mahad work I tried it doesn't work what
does it work I don't love all to work
Javitch ah Bess that's fine I was
carrying your Colwyn nice twist
I'm the sky ah mate I'm gonna die
alright well just God you have left we
were approached we just passed 15
minutes we got town oh ha ha ha
so I hope zombie Bo's got that on camera
know how at the end anyway
ha ha ha now if I just stay here your
bastard to leave me alone hi how do we
have left we have 10 minutes there's
plenty of time don't stand on a jack
what are you doing you have nothing I
know
Nakagawa by iron haha nah oh you have
timing oh [ __ ] I think oh I just got to
defend this one iron block and by the
end of the game I will win
hey these chests were here before this
isn't cool they're empty
yeah are you talking about the grave
chest oh not at all Oh wha what are you
cha what's over there what have you got
way are they gonna lay have you got iron
water Oh huzzah bees I'm unarmed hmm I
see you there Bob huh what I'm not doing
anything I don't know why you're
watching me hah I'm just standing over
here yeah yeah sure yeah I'm just gonna
set this down
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh what's the command to
tell her I don't imagine what's a burger
I just need it no no no no no [ __ ] off
comes daebak Oh
come get me come on bro come get me bro
what are you ganging up on me I don't
know does your body just on a [ __ ]
stole my stuff yeah yeah I now have
three diamond swords oh I'm at a lake
103 you back off
come get me bro no you have iron there
are dirty Wow
I'm unarmed Oh magical chest in the sky
what did that happen never stay away on
watch it that's it y'all back off I'm
gonna get it and you all are gonna gonna
get it if you come hear me if I pray can
I get full of chance at diving or you
know I've covered a gut yard Ark how
much time do we air war to a seven and a
half minutes seven minutes now uh-huh
why would you give this to me now I'm
almost dead hahahaha the terrible time
for the starter kid that's what you
deserve her father attacked me what uh
uh wrong like a playa behind you
you both have what this zombie has
enchanted armor on it Oh
kill him help me help me everybody I'll
give you diamond swords if you help me
kill it I'm coming it's quite violent
although not very harmful your help me
wait don't I know you're trying to get
around into hit me you back to F off
we're all just gonna just team up here
for a moment I look the golems actor
yeah I'm gone but let the Golem get him
get him golden oh yeah get him back go
they need a spawns Ami's yes he spawns
zombies oh I bet this guy has so much
iron wait what what I just dropped out
of the sky
I just dropped out of the sky but why
here he's only a 500 HP hahaha
why wait whoa whoa way to go away wait
you just got too close to me I'm being
chased I see that ah
I'll help you with the Golem if you help
me with the zombie king ah solid golem
hurts yes I thought why aren't you guys
helping me where Bob where did you go no
Bob
why am i by myself on the zombie key fob
that no not fair gonna win the gate
[ __ ] magical being in the sky strike
him down with lightning it's not fair no
being in this guy strike down the wall
and it's all haha do it kill him man
yes I said you working oh my god yo mark
it Stan oh I can't believe that worked
yes now we all have a fair shot at I
know oh oh you were scared of my diamond
yes the desert in time
that's right back off I got this this is
all mine oh I doubt Saira we had we got
far less than five minutes to build a
tower if you have iron you might want to
place it oh man I expected us to be
going much higher than this we don't
have one block I have to you all I have
to do is defend it with my diamond hot
Ward's well all I gotta do let's do what
we were doing let's say a store with
knock-back no you back off I got
spinning blades of death here you don't
even know you don't even know I also
have more than one oh I've got more than
one everybody know that even if you win
the tower challenge you don't actually
win shut up that was a [ __ ] secret
you dick oh you [ __ ] know yes Bob
help oh yeah hahahaha it's only what you
deserve
hi hi I'll kill you with a friggin
shovel you [ __ ]
uh-uh I put on armor Oh God
yeah you know what's gonna do now oh oh
okay that seems like a logical
conclusively [ __ ] Oh Bob are screwed
for the iron bar get away get away get
away get away get away
Hey Oh away Oh get away it's Bob winning
right puffle Bob is not winning I'm
winning
don't tell me you're winning Jack oh no
I got plucked up to the top of the tower
and I don't have a pickaxe
now guy if I can't have it no one can
just under three we got two minutes left
and 15 seconds I've got no I pick oh no
I gotta get some dirt it's like ha ha ha
are we gonna get to it who has a pickaxe
uh-huh
I have all the big axes I think damn it
oh it's time for a last-minute save of
someone maybe in the sky preferably ha
ha hey Mark Hey hi
come over here where did you get stuff
he found I couldn't fit forces oh yeah
me let's countdown smark I want to know
how much time there you got a minute 30
minute 30 in a 30 yea minute 30 you and
all your diamond gear that you stole
from me cuz you all ganged up on me the
tower bro yes it has to be iron you dick
ha ha no gotta be right on top of the
iron I felt me later sorry it does not
work that way
yeah what are we at I'd I'm not telling
you well better tell me you douchebag no
oh you have to tell me that's the only
rule one one minute left one minute one
minute 50 seconds 50 seconds 50 seconds
oh no I gotta back it the zombie king is
back I don't lead him into you bastards
Oh No
I'll kill you no you won't uh wanna bet
okay I think I got iron to win every
loan much time is left I don't know what
20 seconds you guys want to see some
[ __ ] Oh No good 10900 how the [ __ ] did
you get that much iron happen Wow time
time was it in that chest in the sky
that you want did you not notice that I
had a chest in a lake and I was stealing
all your iron blocks the whole time I
don't want a sick thing all I did was
steal your [ __ ] hahaha that was
amazingly clever ha ha oh my god a
40-block tower
alright so um if we didn't spoil the
surprise now zombie gets to declare the
winner [ __ ] you Wade god dammit and
there's no way that strategy wasn't
amazing haha I tried to his amazing
wasabi words the winner by his own
criteria of deviousness Oh cleverness
and anything else so we await your final
verdict whoa oh wait was alright okay so
bob is the winner my scrim is winner of
the first episode of yes of drunk
minecraft he that was amazing you I did
not know yet it that
while you're in the lake so damn night I
never liked it side no your [ __ ] iron
I was so afraid you we're gonna figure
out that there was a chest in the lake
that was incredibly clever I never
thought to hide the iron that I got
until the end so good job on that one
but if I had had my diamond gear it
would all it all banks on that it if you
hadn't been able to sneak in there after
Wade killed me yeah if I hadn't got the
iron gear that would have been much more
difficult but yes that was those that
played out pretty much perfectly for me
all right so congratulations Bob
you win nothing all right absolutely
nothing like old times
you actually if you win you get to say
the outro so I think I think bottom line
it's true yeah do your own outro cuz
this is now your episode you have won
congratulations Bob oh yes yeah so well
thank you everyone for watching if you
liked the video go ahead and subscribe
to Mark's channel I don't have one don't
ask me everyone asked me I don't have a
channel subscribe to Mark's channel and
watch his videos and I guess we'll see
you boys wait wait wait as a channel to
not have to thank you this is my outro
oh it is it true I don't think wait'll
zombie game and yeah thanks to zombie
mould for setting up us on setting us up
on a cool server and Mark and everyone
and see you guys next time we're back
[ __ ]
haha
something funny
well I love
it's fun where are we
40:19
but